bonjour à tous cet après midi les
sénateurs examinent trois propositions
de loi provenant des groupes socialistes
communistes et radicaux
trois textes qui sont identiques et qui
porte sur la compensation des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
versées par les départements
pour les auteurs de ces textes les
départements rencontrent des difficultés
financières qui sont notamment dues aux
charges qui pèsent sur eux au titre de
trois allocations individuelles de
solidarité
le rsa le revenu de solidarité active
l'apa l'allocation personnalisée
d'autonomie et la prestation de
compensation du handicap
ces trois allocations sont effectivement
en hausse sans que cette hausse a
compensé par l'état et donc tout cela
pèse sur le budget des départements tout
de suite direction l'hémicycle pour le
début de la discussion générale c'est
yves daudigny sénateur de l'aisne et co
signataires de cette proposition noir
qui ouvre les débats
monsieur l'allier il rappelle le
règlement
je vous donne la parole sur le président
et de rectification sur des scrutins sur
le numéro 126 sur l'ensemble du projet
de loi de finances pour 2011
monsieur alain fouché a été déclaré
comme votant pour alors qu'il aurait
souhaité s'abstenir et sur le numéro 130
le scrutin 130 sur le moment 34 du
projet de loi de modernisation des
professions judiciaires
sophie joissains françois pillet et
bruno gillon été déclaré comme votant
contre alors qu'ils souhaitaient voter
pour monsieur dernier acte vous est
donnée de la mise au point au sujet d'un
vote
elle sera publiée au journal officiel et
figurera dans la lys politique du
scrutin
l'ordre du jour appelle à 10 ans est
président colin puis nicole borvo oui
monsieur le président madame le ministre
mes chers collègues rappel au règlement
simplement
les messieurs mes chers collègues
rappeler que cet été une délégation de
l'assemblée des départements de france
conduite par son président claudy
lebreton rencontré monsieur le premier
ministre et au cours de cette rencontre
que cette réunion françois fillon a pu
mesurer à travers les propos qui ont été
tenus la situation financière dramatique
dramatique dans laquelle se trouvent
aujourd'hui les conseils généraux de
manière unanime les représentants de
l'adf ont insisté sur l'urgence de
parvenir à un rééquilibrage du
financement des trois allocations
universelles que nous connaissons bien
de solidarité ap ap pch rsa dans l'état
sur une part de plus en plus faible
cette rencontre aura permis d'ailleurs
au premier ministre et à son
gouvernement d'apprécier le caractère
structurel des difficultés de
financement des allocations de
solidarité depuis concernant le rsa de
pch aucun calendrier précis de travail
n'a été proposée par le gouvernement
laisse ainsi les conseils généraux dans
l'incertitude la plus totale quant à
leur avenir immédiat
enfin la mise en place d'un fonds d'aidé
d'urgence sous conditions pour les
départements les plus touchés n'aboutira
qu'à l'encadrement de la libre
administration départementale si la
raison pour laquelle peut dire les
bretons lors de l'assemblée générale qui
s'est tenue des présidents de conseils
généraux qui s'est tenue à avignon à 100
mais général de l'adf a formulé à
proposer en vue unanime qui a été signée
par l'ensemble des présidents toutes
tendances confondues pour mettre en
place une proposition de loi relative à
la compensation des allocations
individuelles de solidarité versées par
les départements et c'est devant ce voeu
unanime et ce souhait exprimé par
l'ensemble des départements que le
groupe les groupes src ps rdse ont pris
l'initiative de déposer cette
proposition de loi dans le cadre de
l'ordre du jour réservé et pour terminer
le ce que je voulais faire remarquer
c'est qu'il semble bien que cette belle
unanimité pour souhaiter la mise en
place de cette loi ne semble pas être
aujourd'hui partagé de façon unanime sur
cet hémicycle
si j'en juge le dérouleur et le peu
d'intérêt qu'a suscité cette proposition
de loi de la part de la majorité
sénatoriale
je vous ça vous voulez au cours de ce
rappel au règlement simplement le faire
remarquer en vous remerciant merci je
suis le président a parlé terrain
présidente nicole borvo cohen seat merci
monsieur le président je veux associer
empêche de tenir des propos voisins de
ceux de mon collègue ils vont colin
parce que pour faire remarquer
effectivement que nous avons eu ici au
sénat souvent l'occasion d'entendre des
représentants des conseils généraux
émettre des avis voisins surtout les
bandes l'hémicycle nous savons combien
le sénat qui représente les
collectivités territoriales se fait fort
de défendre les collectivités
territoriales on a vu ce qu'il en ait
été récemment avec le vote de la réforme
que la majorité a voté mais ceci dit
c'est vrai que l'association des
départements de france et adresser à
tous les groupes que c'est une question
d'importance que elle l'a fait en
représentant je crois la majorité de ses
adhérents et aujourd'hui on peut
constater que d'abord ça ne suscite pas
un intérêt très grand c'est bien qu'ils
aient les intempéries mais enfin de la
majorité et
ça nous voyons aussi que cette
proposition de loi qui ne fait que je
crois traduire le sentiment très
largement partagée des présidents des
conseils généraux et des conseillers
généraux et que ma foi il somme le pack
cette proposition recueille un accord
unanime ce qui est très regrettable
il me représente ce rappel au règlement
sur l'ordre du jour monsieur le
président la commission se rappelle
règlement monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues monsieur
guillaume de 9 12 ans par exemple et non
je vous en prie les jesi rappels au
règlement et le président arthuys après
excusez moi comment tu entendes les
présidents de groupe et les groupes et
puis le ciel gris dentiste donc la
parole et a dit guillaume
puis après jean wilfrid en commission
des finances merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
notre groupe s'associe au rappel
règlement fait par le président colin
est là et la présidente nicole borvo
cohen seat pour dire que aujourd'hui
nous avons une démonstration
c'est la démonstration que la majorité
se fiche éperdument des territoires des
départements de leur situation
financière et des allées des allocations
universelles sociaux social qu'ils sont
donnés au nom du gouvernement au nom de
l'état parlait quand ses généraux c'est
ça la réalité alors que il avait été dit
alors qu'il avait été décidé mais nous
allons nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure
unanimement par l'ensemble des membres
de l'assemblée des départements de
france décident de trouver une solution
afin tout simplement je me permettrai
pas monsieur le ministre de vous
engueuler je ne permettrai pas nous
engueuler et surtout vous êtes là
monsieur le ministre pour kde
mais la réalité elle est celle ci alors
qu'ils avaient été décidés à l'unanimité
à l'unanimité par l'ensemble des
présidents de conseils généraux de
france lors du dernier congrès
qui s'est tenue en avignon il ya cela
quelques semaines d'essayer de trouver
une réponse une solution à l'important
problème que se pose qui est posée à
tous les départements pas uniquement
ceux de gauche également à ceux de
droite qui est celui du financement des
allocations universelles de solidarité
nous pouvons constater malheureusement
le fait que aujourd'hui peut-être mais
nous allons voir dans le débat une
partie des sénateurs
ceux de gauche notamment vont avancer
des propositions et peut-être d'autres
ont été impuissantes et pour le faire
peut-être par des consignes tout
simplement pour d'autres sujets c'est ça
le débat s'est en aucun cas une
accusation
c'est en aucun cas une accusation c'est
un constat et ce rappel au règlement
s'appuie sur l'article que vous le souk
que vous souhaitez monsieur d'allier
mais c'en est un bien mais mes chers
collègues je vais donner la parole à
paul je vais donner la parole à paul
blanc puis au président de la commission
des finances
sachant que ces rappels règlements sont
sur l'ordre du jour mais qu'ils ont un
petit goût d'avant débat que nous
reprendrons après donc je veux d'abord à
la paul blanc puis au président arthuys
et après nous continuons l'ordre du jour
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
quand même rappeler que je ne peux pas
laisser dire que la majorité s'est
désintéressé de ces questions je
rappelle à l'opposition les déclarations
que j'avais fait à l'occasion de
l'examen du budget de la solidarité
nationale le 26 novembre dernier
c'est vrai que vous avez pas pris
longtemps non parce que malheureusement
nous étions en séance que 8 et je le
regrette profondément
je pense que si vous avez été là vous
seriez rendu compte que nous en
préoccupons pions c'est le premier point
deuxième point que je voudrais rappeler
c'est que c'est vrai que il ya quelques
difficultés mais que nous avons aussi
proposé des solutions et dans mon
rapport j'avais effectivement avancer
quelques quelques pistes troisième
réflexion que je voulais faire et quand
même c'est que
c'est solidarité nationale concerne tout
spécialement l'apa et concerne tout
spécialement le handicap la différence
entre vous et nous c'est que quand
lionel jospin a créé la pas rien n'a été
prévu pour la financer pas une seule
ligne n'a été prononcé d'un seul mot a
été prononcé pour essayer de voir
comment on allait la finance et est donc
bien entendu aucun engagement n'a été
pris en ce qui concerne le handicap
sap a été la même chose parce que je
vous rappelle que par rapport à la
création de au moment de la loi la
discussion de la loi du 11 février 2005
que j'ai eu l'honneur leur apporter il
ya eu la création de la caisse nationale
solidarité autonomie qui est financée
qui financent par la journée de travail
supplémentaire
une partie certes c'est peut-être
insuffisant c'est la raison pour
laquelle aussi dans le parmi les
propositions que j'ai fait c'était
éventuellement d'envisager mais c'est
une proposition une journée de
solidarité supplémentaire et donc je ne
peux pas laisser dire que la majorité ne
se préoccupe pas de ce problème et enfin
vous le savez très bien puisque en ce
qui concerne la dépendance qui touche un
petit peu le handicap est bien là aussi
il ya une discussion qui doit
s'effectuer pour essayer de trouver des
solutions de financement
merci monsieur le président de la
commission des finances et puis nous
allons passer à l'ordre du jour après
six ans je vous remercie pour
l'acceptation extensive du rappel au
règlement et ça me permet peut-être de
rappeler quelques quelques points qui
peuvent constituer des jalons pour la
discussion qui s'engage
je pense que aucun d'entre nous ne peut
se prévaloir du monopole de la défense
des départements mais j'aurais
simplement vous rappeler que nous venons
de voter le projet de loi de finances
pour 2011
en essayant de contenir le déficit et
qui ne sera que de 92 milliards et je
fais observer aux auteurs de cette
proposition de loi est que cette belle
contribution pour les appartements a
pour conséquence d'augmenter la dépense
publique
en tout cas le déficit de l'état de 3
milliards 400 millions
je voudrais vous dire qu'entre temps il
s'est produit un phénomène d'apaisement
pour les départements puisque le produit
des droits de mutation à titre
obligatoire à progresser en 2010 d'un
milliard 800 millions que le sénat vient
de voter un fonds de péréquation ddm
théo qui s'élève à 380 millions et que
l'apport qui va revenir un certain
nombre de départements la plupart des
départements est significatif et que par
conséquent les difficultés si aiguë dont
il avait été fait écho lors de la
récente assemblée générale des
départements de france se trouve quelque
peu relativisé je ne dis pas que le
produit ddm t au et du fonds de
péréquation sera aussi important en 2012
qu'en 2011 mais pour l'immédiat
il me semble que nous avons un début
d'apaisement pour régler au mieux cet
effet de ciseaux qu'au surplus
les députés sont saisis d'un projet de
loi de finances rectificative qui
comporte un supplément de crédit de 150
millions pour ceux des départements qui
se trouvent confrontés à des difficultés
particulières et que ceci est de nature
à apaiser certaines des craintes
exprimées que d'autres départements par
pragmatisme on dans un esprit
visionnaire augmenter très sensiblement
les taxes foncières pour réduire
corrélativement les taxes d'habitation
je pense aux départements de l'aisne et
peut-être que monsieur daudigny nous
dira comment il vit cette
expérimentation qui a pour conséquence
d'assécher les ressources des communes
et communautés de communes au profit des
départements
donc on voit que chacun a su trouvé une
martingale pour se sortir au mieux de
ses difficultés ayant dit cela
peut-être faudra-t-il aussi aller cher
collègue vers d'autres mesures plus
radicales
pourrons-nous durablement équilibrer les
finances publiques en maintenant la
durée du temps de travail en deçà de 35
heures je ne le crois pas et donc au
delà des considérations dogmatique
partisane qui sont les clés d'accès au
pouvoir
peut-être faut-il sortir les uns et les
autres du déni de réalité qui fait
offense aux réponses d'optimisme et de
confiance
qu'attendent les français
bien oui chers collègues même si j'ai le
sentiment que ces rappels au règlement
ont déjà un permis ont déjà permis un
avant-goût y de notre les 20 points dit
je ne pense pas pour autant que vous
vous soyez complètement exprimé
peut-être avez-vous encore quelques
considérations à faire donc je vous
rappelle que d'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
relative à la compensation des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
versées par les départements proposition
de loi présentée par jean-pierre bel
clodo yves krattinger gérard miquel et
les membres du groupe socialiste
apparentés et rattachés et que la
conférence des présidents
comme l'a rappelé le président colin a
décidé que serait jointe à cette
proposition deux propositions de loi
identiques présentés par yvon collin
jean michel bailly les plaisirs de nos
collègues du groupe rdse et nicole borvo
cohen seat marie france beaufils odette
terrade jean françois voguet mireille
kurt elling celle-ci josiane
mathon-poinat les membres du groupe crc
dans la discussion générale
la parole est un autre collègue yves
daudigny groupe pour le groupe
socialiste yves daudigny co signataire
de la proposition de loi pour
minute sachant que nous enfermer dans un
délai qui ne peut dépasser 4 heures
mon cher collègue nous écoutons monsieur
le président madame la ministre monsieur
rapportant mes chers collègues
l'heure est grave pour les départements
français l'heure est grave car ils sont
aujourd'hui confrontés aux pires
difficultés financières qu'il n'ait
jamais connue depuis l'acte 1 de la
décentralisation il ya maintenant près
de 30 ans et ceci monsieur le président
la commission des finances
malgré les éléments que vous venez de
citer c'est donc avec beaucoup de
détermination et conviction que je vais
présenter aujourd'hui devant vous cette
proposition de loi relative à la
compensation des allocations
individuelles de solidarité versée par
les conseils généraux déposée par mon
groupe mais également dans nos collègues
des groupe rdse et crc spg
cette proposition est le fruit d'un
travail de longue haleine mené par les
parlementaires et par les départements
eux mêmes au sein de l'assemblée des
départements de france sous la houlette
de son président claudy lebreton et de
michele dean et son premier
vice-président puisqu'ils sont présents
en tribune aujourd'hui pour assister à
ce débat important
je voudrais en profiter pour les saluer
chaleureusement ainsi que les présidents
de conseils généraux
assis à leurs côtés quelle que soit leur
sensibilité
car ce texte il faut insister sur ce
point n'est pas une opération de
communication partisane dans le cas
présent il n'y a pas d'un côté les
départements de gauche ou du centre qui
s'opposent au gouvernement et de l'autre
les départements présidées par des élus
de la majorité présidentielle qui
soutiennent ce même gouvernement l'enjeu
transcende
ici les clivages politiques
traditionnels
depuis le début nous sommes appuyés sur
le travail collégial entrepris par
l'assemblée des départements de france
qui a d'ailleurs fait elle même le choix
du pluralisme et de la responsabilité
sur ce dossier je reviendrai dans
quelques minutes sur les principes
énoncés par ce texte
ceux ci sont issus de la démarche lancée
par les présidents des départements dans
le cadre de leur association
il y à plus d'un an
on mars dernier à l'unanimité les
présidents de conseils généraux du
bureau de l'adf décide de l'urgence de
conduire un travail sur le financement
durable des allocations individuelles de
solidarité et de la nécessité de
proposer des mesures législatives au
parlement à partir de cette date
plusieurs dizaines de départements de
gauche comme de droite ont travaillé
pendant plusieurs semaines avec l'aide
de spécialistes à l'élaboration d'un
texte législatif qui s'approche de celui
dont nous débattons aujourd'hui la
première version de cette proposition de
loi fut présenté aux présidents de
conseils généraux
deux généraux à la fin août ce jour là
le bureau de l'adf a donné mandat à son
président claudy lebreton pour
poursuivre le processus notamment par la
rencontre de l'ensemble des responsables
de notre assemblée présidence groupes
politiques commissions des finances et
des affaires sociales avec beaucoup de
pédagogie
l'adf a détaillé les tenants et les
aboutissants de la démarche engagée
l'accueil et l'écouté qui lui fut
réservé par chacun d'entre vous à cette
occasion au nord le sénat ces échanges
de grande qualité ont incontestablement
nourrit la proposition de loi et le
texte qui a été déposée sur le bureau de
notre assemblée n'aurait pas été ce
qu'il est censé échanges constructifs
convaincu de l'importance de ce texte
trois groupes ont donc décidé de son
apparaît afin qu'il puisse connaître un
véritable débouché parlementaire en
déposant cette proposition pour un
examen par notre assemblée
nous avons ainsi fait écho à la demande
unanime des 102 présidente département
réunit les 20 et 21 octobre dernier à
avignon pour le 80e congrès de l'adf
je cite la résolution unanime de ce
dernier congrès les présidentes et
présidents de conseils généraux sont
satisfaits de l'accueil réservé à cette
proposition et espère que les conditions
seront réunies pour qu'elle aboutisse
à la compensation quasi intégral des
trois allocations
le texte que nous allons examiner
aujourd'hui a donc une histoire et une
légitimité il a été mûrement réfléchie
et permet enfin d'ouvrir au sein de la
représentation nationale un débat très
attendu par la france des départements
mais aussi et surtout par nos millions
de concitoyens concernés par ces
prestations sociales universelles
la notion de solidarité nationale est au
coeur de notre démarche et il faut bien
mesurer ici le rôle spécifique des
départements en la matière les conseils
généraux sont en effet les seules
collectivités territoriales a versé pour
le compte de l'état des allocations
individuelles de solidarité
ces dernières et je reprendrai ici
l'exposé des motifs du présent texte
constitue un droit voté par le parlement
et auquel peut accéder une personne âgée
pour compenser la perte d'autonomie due
à son âge c'est l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie
une personne qui ne touchent pas
suffisamment de revenus pour vivre
dignement
c'est le revenu de solidarité active
auparavant revenu minimum d'insertion
une personne handicapée pour adapter son
environnement
de telle sorte qu'elles puissent vivre
pleinement sa vie et ses projets c'est
la prestation de compensation du
handicap
toute personne accède à ce droit sur la
base d'un examen de sa situation
individuelle qui donne lieu à un plan
daide ou à contrat régulièrement évalués
au regard de l'évolution de la situation
de chaque personne
en résumé une allocations individuelles
de solidarité
c'est une somme d'argent attribué à une
personne sur la base à la fois d'un
droit établi nationalement et d'une
évaluation individuelle et régulière
de la situation de chaque personne lapin
la pch et le rsa son nom par essence des
prestations universelles de même nature
que les allocations familiales dont
personne ne songerait ici à remettre en
cause le paiement intégral par l'état
sans vouloir faire offense au rapporteur
de la commission des finances ne nous
plaçons pas ici dans un débat juridique
pour savoir si ces allocations ont fait
l'objet d'un transfert de compétences ou
d'une création de compétences à la
charge des départements
nous affirmons ici un principe général
celui du financement par la solidarité
nationale d'allocation imaginé dans le
droit fil du programme du conseil
national de la résistance
le préambule de la constitution de 1946
intégré dans celui de notre constitution
actuelle défini extrêmement bien ce
principe
il dispose ainsi je cite que tout être
humain qui en raison de son âge son état
physique ou mental de sa situation
économique se trouve dans l'incapacité
de travailler a le droit d'obtenir de la
collectivité des moyens convenables
convenables d'existence c'est bien ce
fondement essentiel de notre pacte
social républicain que nous souhaitons
défendre à travers ce texte
néanmoins monsieur rapporteur quand bien
même sur yevou insensible à ces
arguments
nous sommes prêts à débattre avec vous
la question de la libre administration
des collectivités territoriales
peut-être avez-vous raison juridiquement
sur l'absence d'obligation
constitutionnel de financement intégral
par l'état de l'apa et du rsa compte
tenu des régimes législatif sur
lesquelles elles ont été créées
mais c'est précisément la raison pour
laquelle nous souhaitons revoir la
législation qui s'applique et clarifier
les choses
aujourd'hui afin de remettre à plat le
financement de ce dispositif qui ont été
conçus à une époque où certes la
situation économique était plus stable
et les finances publiques
plus sereine n'est ce pas notre rôle
nous parlementaires de revisiter les
textes que nous avons pu adopter pour
les rendre cohérent avec l'évolution de
notre société aujourd'hui le gouffre
entre les dépenses réalisées par les
départements pour payer les trois
allocations et les recettes transférées
par le niveau national
à ce titre est de plus en plus vertige
et nous devons nous partager ce constat
et doria proposé que dire de la
responsabilité du parlement
si celui ci n'est pas en mesure de
construire une réponse collective à
cette situation inédite
aujourd'hui avec un tel déficit de
financement ne peut-on pas parlé d'
atteinte à la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales
je note d'ailleurs que c'est sur ce
fondement qu'une soixantaine de
départements s'apprête à saisir le
conseil constitutionnel à travers le
mécanisme de la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité qpc
mes chers collègues nous sommes plongés
depuis plusieurs semaines dans le débat
budgétaire
cette proposition de loi arrive donc au
bon moment car nous savons tous qu'à
travers ce texte c'est à une question de
société que nous répondons il s'agit
donc clairement d'un choix politique que
le parlement doit faire pour garantir à
nos concitoyens qui en ont besoin une
protection à la hauteur de notre
histoire contemporaine
c'est pourquoi nous préconisons et j'en
viens donc à l'explication de la
proposition de loi en elle-même la
compensation quasi intégrale de trois
allocations
le texte que nous vous soumettons
prévoit que cette compensation sera
assurée après consultation de la
commission consultative sur l'évaluation
des charges et sera déterminé par la loi
de finances selon les modalités
habituelles fiscalité aux dotations
budgétaires les six articles de la
présente proposition de loi viennent
d'en préciser
les modalités de ce rééquilibrage du
financement de ces trois allocations
l'article premier vise à modifier la loi
du 1er décembre 2008 généralisant le rsa
et réformant les politiques d'insertion
de façon à ce qu'à compter de 2010 et
pour l'exercice 2011 la compensation des
charges résultant du transfert du rmi et
de l'extension du rsa soit réajuster
chaque année après avis de la commission
consultative sur l'évaluation des
charges les articles 2 à 4 concernent
l'allocation personnalisée pour
l'autonomie
il prévoit ainsi d'une manière générale
qu'à compter de 2010 les charges
résultant pour les départements des
prestations versées au titre de l'apa à
domicile ou en établissement sont
compensés sur la base des dépenses
constatées au dernier compte
administratif des conseils généraux
après avis de la cco si je ne rentre pas
dans les détails des différents calculs
proposé à cet effet mais il convient de
préciser que le dispositif envisagé
prend en compte ce que le département
finance et avant la création de l'apa
c'est à dire la psd prestation
spécifique dépendance
dans ces conditions nous avons instauré
un mécanisme qui déduit du droit à
compensation le montant actualisé de
cette ps et psd et qui instaure ce que
doc a notamment appellent un ticket
modérateur à la charge des départements
l'article 5 temps pour sa part à ce que
les charges supportées par les
départements au titre de la pch soit
compensée sur la base des dépenses
constatées au dernier compte
administratif des conseils généraux
enfin l'article 6 prévoit que le
gouvernement prendra par ordonnance les
mesures nécessaires à l'application des
dispositions envisagées par la présente
loi
odom ces dispositions ont le mérite de
la clarté de la liste
visiter et de l'efficacité
malheureusement si on en croit le
rapporteur
elle y réussit tout dans le sens d'une
déresponsabilisation des départements
dans la gestion des allocations pardon
de vous contredire une nouvelle fois
monsieur guinée mais vous semblez
méconnaître la le fonctionnement réel de
nos collectivités les élus qui dirige
les départements de france ne sont pas
des irresponsables
pourquoi estimez-vous de la sorte que
ces derniers ne sont pas capables de
gérer avec le même sérieux
l'argent des contribuables locaux et
celui des contribuables nationaux
les conseillers généraux ne sont pas des
enfants il pilote l'action sociale
locale depuis maintenant près de 30 ans
et ils ont désarmé
désormais toute la légitimité pour le
faire
j'ajoute deux éléments 1 si la
conférence sur le déficit public
initié par le gouvernement a eu un
mérite c'est bien de montrer que ce ne
sont pas les collectivités qui sont
responsables du déficit public et qu'en
matière de gestion celles ci n'ont pas
de leçons à recevoir
2 la responsabilité je parle de la notre
responsabilité
elle est bien là car la couverture qui
est demandé outre qu'elle prend en
compte ce que le département finance et
déjà ne concernent surtout que le
montant c'est aux sangsues des
allocations en aucune manière notre
proposition de loi ne vise à financer la
mise en oeuvre par les départements la
distribution de ces allocations
que ce soit les personnels dédiés ou les
moyens administratifs consentis monsieur
le rapporteur avance également dans ce
rapport que d'une manière générale la
réforme proposée je cite remettrait en
cause le principe même de la
décentralisation du rmi et de la gestion
décentralisée de la pch
mes chers collègues je vous le dis tout
net pourquoi en lisant cette phrase
avons-nous la désagréable sensation que
décentralisation est ici employé comme
synonyme de désengagement transférer des
compétences de quelque nature que ce
soit à
échelon infra étatiques pour en
améliorer la gestion ne signifie pas
automatiquement réduction drastique des
coûts pour l'état de la politique en
question
pour le cas d'espèce le coût de la
location décidé au niveau national
devrait incomber à combes est
intégralement à l'étang si ces derniers
avaient encore la gestion du rsa il
serait d'ailleurs bien obligé de verser
les sommes nécessaires aux bénéficiaires
cette vision de la décentralisation ne
saurait être la nôtre d'ailleurs
l'apport fondamental des collectivités
en la matière est bel et bien à chercher
dans le véritable savoir faire qu'elle
possède en matière de proximité
cette gestion efficace au plus près des
besoins de nos concitoyens et bien
entendu source d'économie et permettent
ainsi une utilisation équilibrée de la
dépense publique
je suis certain d'ailleurs que mes
collègues par la suite du débat ne
manqueront pas de décrire le dynamisme
et politiques mises en oeuvre par les
collectivités territoriales vaut leur ai
bien compris cette proposition de loi et
cela a été dit avant a donc un coût
celui de la mise en oeuvre d'une
solidarité nationale juste efficace et
pérenne
selon le rapporteur je cite le coût pour
l'état de l'adoption de ces propositions
de loi aurait été de l'ordre de 3 34
milliards d'euros en 2009
ce qui n'apparaît pas réaliste dans le
contexte actuel des finances publiques
et vous ne l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président de la commission il semble en
revanche réaliste que le gouvernement
compte sur les départements pour assumer
cette solidarité nationale il semble
juste pour le gouvernement d'accorder
depuis 2007 plusieurs milliards d'euros
d'exonérations fiscales du secteur
économique à destination de telle frange
de la population
c'est un choix politique qu'il convient
de faire
aujourd'hui en faveur de l'égalité de la
justice sociale de notre pacte social
républicain
je souhaite que mes collègues lors de la
q sion général et vac plus en détail
cette question des ressources à
mobiliser pour financer cette
proposition de loi
je compte sur eux pour faire preuve
d'imagination de réalisme d'équité de
solidarité et je sais que des idées
existe sur tous les bancs de l'hémicycle
monsieur rapporteur justifie en face une
opposition à cette proposition de loi
par la nécessité de ne pas
court-circuiter les travaux en cours et
notamment l'ouverture du chantier la
dépendance annoncée par le président de
la république
soulignons deux points à le déséquilibre
de financement des trois allocations
reconnaissons le ça a été dit ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui de ce gouvernement et
dès la mise en oeuvre de l'apa ou du rmi
rsa des écarts entre les recettes et les
dépenses ont été identifiés 2
la réforme de la dépendance déjà promise
un nombreuses fois ces dernières années
n'abordera que la question certes
essentielle mais la seule question des
personnes âgées en perte d'autonomie
il est donc de ma responsabilité de dire
que nous ne pouvons pas attendre le 1er
janvier 2012 pour que ne soient traitées
et de quelle manière cela reste encore à
construire qu'une seule des trois
allocations visé enfin et surtout la
prééminence d'un débat malfoy annoncé
reporter sur la prise en charge de
personnes dépendantes âgées et ou
handicapées n'exclut en rien que soit
actée dès aujourd'hui par ce texte le
principe de la compensation intégrale
des allocations individuelles de
solidarité par les temps pour conclure
je voudrais vous dire mes chers
collègues convient il faut aborder le
problème du financement de ces
allocations comme une question
spécifique au département il n'existe
aucun autre exemple répondant aux mêmes
caractéristiques
contrairement à la fosse comparaison qui
est fait avec les transferts de
compétences qui ont eu lieu lors de la
mise en oeuvre premières lois de
décentralisation le financement de ces
allocations est d'une autre nature tout
en aidant financé par le département
c'est toujours le parlement qui fixe le
montant de l'apa et de la pch et du rsa
socle
et leurs conditions d'attribution ainsi
dans le même temps où ses
responsabilités sont assumés par le
département les lois fixe étroitement le
cadre et les conditions dans lequel les
collectivités doivent les exercer
comparons avec une autre compétence
transférée les collèges c'est le
département seuls qui fixe le rythme et
le montant des investissements qui
décide de faire si l'assemblée
départementale
seul qui est redevable devant les
concitoyens de ses choix
d'investissement une seconde nuances
existent et aller de talent c'est
l'énormité des masses financières
concernées par les décalages et leur
accroissement qui sera de plus en plus
important
comment aujourd'hui aborder cette
question d'abord on en fermant pas on ne
l'en ferment pas dans le problème des
sols ressources mais en la posant au
regard de son rapport au budget de
l'état avec les questions qui y sont
liés celle de l'impôt de la csg
ensuite en imposant au regard du bilan
que nous devons faire du pacte
républicain de solidarité et du contrat
social issu du programme du conseil
national de la résistance car les
réponses durables à construire
concernant les allocations se pose dans
les mêmes termes que celles qui sont à
construire concernant la santé les
retraites et la famille le temps est
venu je vais conclure aujourd'hui de
reconstruire ensemble à la fois en
france et sur le continent européen
un nouveau contrat social ferment d'un
vivre ensemble
confortés et durablement fraternelle le
sort des allocations individuelles de
solidarité participe de ce débat et non
d'une préoccupation comptable c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous demande
chers collègues en dépit des réserves
formulées par la commission le
gouvernement d'adopter ce texte
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci mon cher collègue
dans la discussion générale la parole et
un charles guené rapporteur de la
commission des finances monsieur
rapporteur
monsieur le président madame le ministre
mes chers collègues nous examinons
aujourd'hui trois propositions de loi
identiques à relative à la compensation
des allocations individuelles de
solidarité versées par les départements
les trois allocations visés sont le
revenu de solidarité active l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie et la
prestation de compensation du handicap
ces propositions de loi qui ont été
examinés par la commission des finances
le 30 novembre dernier en même temps que
les articles non rattachés la seconde
partie du projet de loi de finances que
nous avons voté avant-hier émane du
groupe socialiste du groupe communiste
et de 12 de nos collègues du groupe rdse
par ses propositions de loi les auteurs
ont voulu mettre l'accent
à juste titre me semble-t-il sur des
difficultés financières que rencontrent
les départements dans leur ensemble ces
difficultés résonne résulte notamment
les charges qui pèsent sur eux qui
pèsent sur eux au titre des trois
allocations visés par les propositions
de lois difficultés dont nous avons
entendu à travers les propos du
président a retué qu'elles peuvent être
aujourd'hui relativiser ont vu des
diverses évolutions un mot de cadrage
d'abord même si le droit vous dérange
parfois sur les compensations versées au
titre de ces trois allocations en
commençant par le rmi et le rmi le rsa
le transfert du rmi puisqu'il s'agit
d'un transfert aux départements en 2004
a bien été qualifié au regard de
l'article 72-2 de la constitution de
transfert de compétences il en résulte
que l'état a une obligation de
transférer au département des ressources
équivalentes à celles qu'il consacrait à
cette compétence avant son transfert
cela a été fait par l' attribution de
fraction de taxe intérieure sur les
produits pétroliers
cette obligation a même été dépassé
puisque à l'initiative de notre
commission des finances l'état verse au
département 500 millions d'euros
supplémentaires par an au titre des
fonds de mobilisation départemental pour
l'insertion
la généralisation du rsa a en 2009 et
est qualifiée de simple extension de
compétences des départements et non de
transfert l'état n'a donc pour
obligation constitutionnelle que de
transférer des ressources permettant de
préserver le principe de la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales
il a toutefois fait le choix de procéder
à une compensation similaire à celle du
rmi par versement d'une fraction de thé
ip paix qui sera figé sur le montant des
dépenses engagées par les départements
au titre du rsa en 2010 en 2009 le
montant de la compensation versée par
l'état au titre du rsa s'est élevée au
total à 5 76 milliards d'euros le
montant à la charge des départements a
été de 6 47 milliards d'euros et par
conséquent le montant non compensés par
l'état a été de 708 6 millions soit un
taux de couverture de 80 9%
le financement de l'apa et de la pch
obéissent à une logique différente
la création de l'apa en 2002 et celle de
la pch en 2006 n'ont pas non plus
constituer des transferts de compétences
seul l'objectif constitutionnel de
préservation du principe de la ligne de
la libre administration s'applique donc
aucun dispositif de compensation des
charges par transfert de fiscalité n'a
été mise en place
c'est la caisse nationale de solidarité
pour l'autonomie la cns a qui
participent au financement de ces
dispositifs qui sont à la charge des
départements
la section 2 du budget de l'apn et
sartre à 100 recettes des contributions
sociales qui sont affectés à la
participation au titre de l'apa le
montant de la contribution de la cn et
ça n'est donc pas corrélées au coût de
l'apa il évolue en fonction du produit
des contributions en 2009 la cn et ça a
contribué à hauteur de 1,55 milliard
d'euros au financement de l'apa pour un
coût global de 5,03 milliards d'euros
pour les départements soit un reste à
charge de 3 48 milliards d'euros
correspondant à un taux de couverture
je dirais de seulement 30 8 % ce taux de
couverture étant en diminution linéaire
depuis 2002 où il s'élevait rappelons le
à 43%
la section 3 du budget de la cns à
retrace pour sa part les dépenses
affectées à sa participation au titre de
la pch
dans ce cas non plus le montant de la
contribution de la scène et ça n'est pas
corrélé au coût de la pch pour les
départements en 2009 la contribution de
la cns a au titre d'un pch s'est élevé à
5 109 7 millions d'euros à comparer à un
coût global pour les départements de
843,3 millions d'euros soit un montant
compensé de 333 6 millions d'euros et à
tout doux et un taux de couverture cette
fois de 70 4%
je signale que du fait du montant global
de la participation de la seleçao
financement de la pch ce il est sans
lien avec le coût de la pch
le taux de couverture a été les deux
premières années de création de la pch
supérieur à 100% il l'est encore
d'ailleurs pour certains départements
ces trois propositions de loi vise donc
principalement en réalité qu'on nous en
ensemble à réformer le financement de la
dépendance
si on fait le bilan du reste à charge
pour les départements au titre des trois
allocations versées on obtient un
montant de 4 52 milliards d'euros pour
2009 la part représente à elle seule 70
7% de ce coup puisqu'elle atteint 3,48
milliards d'euros en coût net de la
participation de la scène et ça pour les
départements s'ajoute à ce constat le
fait qu'en dynamique
c'est également la pac qui pèsera à
moyen et long termes sur les budgets
départementaux
en effet le coup lui rsa varie avec la
conjoncture économique
il diminue nettement lors des phases de
reprise de croissance avec la
contraction nette du nombre de ses
bénéficiaires
ainsi on l'a vu -12% en 2005 et 2008 par
exemple le coût de la pch quant à lui 1
fortement augmenté ces dernières années
mais cette hausse correspond pas
si palm ans à la montée en charge d'un
dispositif relativement nouveau il n'y a
pas de raison qu à moyen terme le coût
de la pch qui bénéficie aux populations
handicapées ne se stabilise pas la
situation est tout autre pour l'apa en
effet comme l'a notamment relevé le
rapport de notre mission commune
d'information sur le cinquième risque
présidée par notre collègue fille marie
ni le coût de la prise en charge de la
dépendance augmentera nécessairement
avec le doublement d'ici 2050 de la
proportion des personnes âgées de 75 ans
dans l'ensemble de la population
française
si le coup d' appât est aujourd'hui le
plus élevé pour les finances
départementales
c'est aussi celui qui devrait augmenter
le plus or ce coup s'inscrit dans un
contexte financier difficile pour les
départements comme l'a relevé le rapport
sur les finances départementales rédigé
par pierre jamet
les départements ont connu ces dix
dernières années un effet de ciseaux
incontestable entre la progression de
leurs recettes et de leurs dépenses en
fonctionnement les dépenses ont en effet
globalement augmenté de 2 % de plus par
an que les ressources
ce contexte s'est aggravée que la crise
économique récente qui a produit un
triple effet le nombre de bénéficiaires
du rsa a fortement augmenté + 16 % entre
juin 2009 et juin 2010 les contributions
de la scène et ça se sont réduites du
fait de la diminution du produit des
cotisations sociales
affecté au département et enfin les
recettes des droits de mutation à titre
onéreux des départements se sont
effondrés - 33 % en 2007 et 2009 alors
que les dm théo représentent environ 20%
des recettes fiscales des départements
alors ce sont des propos qui méritent
d'être nuancés comme nous l'avons évoqué
au départ avec le président arthuis mais
ce sont quand même des réalités qu'elle
est dans ce contexte la solution
préconisée par les propositions pour le
rsa et la pch les propositions de loi
préconise une solution simple l'état
prendrait à sa charge l'intégralité du
coût de ses prestations supporté par les
départements
chaque année au vu des comptes
administratifs l'état compenserait à
l'euro près le reste à charge des
départements
le coût de cette solution pour l'état
aurait été en 2009 de 708 millions
d'euros au titre du rsa est de 3 333
millions au titre de la pch pour l'apa
la solution est un peu différente
en effet les propositions de lois
maintiennent à la charge des
départements un ticket modérateur de 10%
l'état ne comprend serait donc que 90 %
des dépenses d'un pas des départements
en outre cette compensation ne porterait
pas sur le montant de la prestation
spécifique dépendance la psd que la part
en place progressivement par conséquent
le coût de cette solution pour l'état
peut être évaluée à 2,3 milliards
d'euros pour 2009 au titre de l'apa au
final les propositions de loi vise à
transférer des départements à l'état une
charge correspondante à 3,34 milliards
d'euros sans modifier les dispositions
du rsa et de l'apa ou de la pch et
surtout sans proposer la création de
nouvelles recettes
c'est le point qui constitue pour moi la
principale lacune des propositions de
loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui je ne
peux préconisé l'adoption de ces
propositions de loi pour plusieurs
raisons
d'une part comme nous l'avons vu elle
vise principalement à modifier la prise
en charge financière de la dépendance
or il ne vous a pas échappé que le
président de la république annoncé le 16
novembre dernier un débat national sur
ce sujet qui doit se tenir dans le
courant de l'année 2011
ce débat sera suivi d'une réforme
législative qui devrait être intégrée au
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2012
il serait particulièrement malvenu au
moment où certains se sont émus du
manque de concertation préalable à la
réforme des retraites le court circuiter
le débat qui nous est proposé je signale
par ailleurs que le sénat a contribué et
va contribuer à ce débat avec sa mission
commune d'information sur le cinquième
risque
par ailleurs la solution proposée n'est
pas satisfaisante pour plusieurs raisons
de fond
la compensation à l'euro près des
dépenses de rsa et le pch conduirait à
déresponsabiliser totalement les
départements dans la mise en oeuvre de
ces politiques
or un des avantages majeurs de leur
gestion décentralisée et qui sont mieux
géré que si c'était que si la cnaf le
faisait au niveau national puisque c'est
l'intérêt financier du département de le
faire de manière fine
certes le départ que les départements ne
décide pas du montant du rsa ni des
critères d'attribution
il est toutefois responsable de la
gestion du fichier des allocataires de
sa mise à jour des radiations et il
résiste
il résulte de cette gestion des
économies subventions substantielles et
le premier vice président du conseil
général que je suis en convient tout à
fait monsieur dodille d'autre part le
ticket modérateur de 10 % proposés pour
la part paraît relativement faible on
regarde la répartition actuelle de cette
charge
un débat doit avoir lieu sur cette
question enfin le coût pour l'état de la
solution proposée qui aurait été de 3 34
milliards d'euros en 2009 je vous le
rappelle si elle avait été mise en
oeuvre est excessive et irréaliste dans
le contexte le contexte actuel des
finances de l'état je rappelle que le
déficit budgétaire de l'état pour
l'année 2011 sera de 92 milliards
d'euros après un déficit de 152
milliards d'euros en 2010 je relève pour
conclure que la solution proposée par
les trois textes que nous examinons
aujourd'hui reviendrait peu ou prou à
remettre en cause le principe même de la
décentralisation de ses allocations
en effet
quel serait l'intérêt de faire gérer par
nos collectivités territoriales des
compétences dont le le coup leur serait
quoi qu'il arrive intégralement
compensés par l'état
c'est donc pour l'ensemble les raisons
que je viens d'évoquer que je ne suis
pas favorable à ces trois propositions
de loi la commission des finances a
toutefois décidé de ne pas élaborer de
textes propre et de discuter ici en
séance publique sur la rédaction de nos
collègues
elle souhaite donc le rejette chacun des
articles qui composent de ses
propositions de lois de l'ensemble des
textes
je vous remercie pour votre attention
merci chers collègues norris fille
d'annie oger la parole est à mme
marie-anne montchamp secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre des solidarités et
de la cohésion sociale madame le
ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président se présente la commission des
finances monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
je suis heureuse d'avoir l'occasion à la
faveur de l'examen de ces propositions
doit de répondre devant la haute
assemblée aux débats qui traversent
depuis plusieurs mois en effet cela a
été dit les départements de france les
auteurs de ces ppl ont voulu mettre
l'accent sur les difficultés financières
qu'il rencontre du fait notamment des
charges qui pèsent sur eux au titre des
trois dispositifs de solidarité vivait
par les propositions de loi je veux
parler du revenu de solidarité active de
l'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie
et de la prestation de compensation du
handicap si le constat de ces
difficultés et bien évidemment partagé
la solution apportée par ces
propositions de loi nous est apparu
quelque peu inadapté à la nature des
questions que par ailleurs pose ses
propositions de loi question qu en effet
l'assemblée des départements de france a
soulevé d'abord le gouvernement est
conscient des difficultés
conjoncturelles mais aussi des
difficultés structurelles rencontrées
par les départements les difficultés des
départements s'explique d'abord par des
facteurs structurels
le rythme de progression des dépenses
sociales obéit à des tendances en partie
structurelle elles sont tantôt négatives
c'est l'apparition de nouvelles formes
de précarité c'est la dégradation du
marché du travail en raison de la crise
tantôt des tendances que l'on pourrait
qualifier de positive et donc il faut se
réjouir collectivement c'est le
vieillissement de notre société de notre
population avec ans particulièrement
l'allongement de la durée de vie et des
phénomènes qui l'accompagnent qui sont
souvent heureux ces évolutions ne touche
pas seulement la france
elle touche l'ensemble des démocraties
occidentales et notamment les
démocraties européennes qui sont
confrontés mais il est clair que
l'impact en france est particulièrement
fort ainsi s'agissant du vieillissement
de la population on s'attend à compter
un million quatre cent mille personnes
âgées en perte d'autonomie dès 2040
c'est beaucoup nous sommes donc face à
un enjeu de société face un défi social
mais aussi à un défi financier l'état a
engagé des réformes importantes pour
toujours mieux répondre aux besoins
croissants des personnes en perte
d'autonomie et de leurs familles par
l'instauration dette financière
spécifique
la loi du 20 juillet 2001 a ainsi créé
l'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie
celle du 11 février 2005
shared paul blanc en faveur des
personnes handicapées a notamment créé
la prestation de compensation du
handicap
par ailleurs le revenu de solidarité
active créé par la loi du 1er décembre
2008 a pris la suite du revenu minimum
d'insertion et de l'allocation parent
isolé par le rsa socle
maj majoré à partir du 1er juin 2009
après une phase d'expérimentation menée
grâce à des départements volontaires
pour en tester la pertinence au total en
les dépenses d'aidé sociale prise en
charge par les départements ont
représenté 12 4 milliards d'euros au
titre de la paix a de la pch et du rsa
mais avec la crise l'augmentation de ses
dépenses sociales s'est amplifiée alors
que les recettes des départements se
sont contractés créant un effet de
ciseaux particulièrement marqué cela a
été dit cet écart entre l'évolution des
recettes et des dépenses est accentuée
depuis le deuxième semestre de l'année
2008 en raison de trois facteurs
résultant directement de la crise
économique
c'est le nombre de bénéficiaires du rsa
qui a considérablement augmenté un
million cent quarante mille
bénéficiaires du rmi en juin 2008 contre
un million trois cent trente mille
allocataires du rsa socle en juin 2010
16% plus en deux ans les recettes de
cotisations sociales perçues par la cns
a ont diminué du fait du ralentissement
de l'activité économique enfin la
contraction des recettes a
particulièrement touché la fiscalité
indirecte avec une chute des droits de
mutation à titre onéreux dû au
retournement du marché immobilier
pendant la crise je note cependant que
cette tendance s'est depuis inversée
puisque fans novembre 2010 les dm théo
avait progressé de 36% par rapport à
leur niveau de novembre 2009
fin novembre 2010 il s'établissait à un
peu plus de 5 millions 900 mille euros
soit d'ores et déjà près de 2 milliards
pardonnez-moi euros soit près de 500
millions d'euros de plus que sur
l'ensemble de l'année 2009 une année
pour laquelle il s'était élevé à 5,2
milliards d'euros
enfin j'ajoute que l'ampleur de cet
effet de ciseaux n'a pas été le même
d'un département à l'autre cet aspect
est extrêmement important c'est un fait
incontestable les pratiques locales sont
diverses les héritages de la gestion
passée les réalités démographiques les
réalités sociales économiques sont
propres à chaque département la france
des territoires et fait deux réalités
multiples les pratiques locales y sont
donc varié et ils sont souvent
hétérogènes
les rapports du groupe de travail
présidé par gilles carez et michel
thénault
celui de pierre jamet ont démontré à
l'évidence cette diversité aussi je suis
bien consciente de la situation
difficile dans laquelle se trouve un
certain nombre de départements c'est
même pour cela que je peux affirmer que
les réponses apportées par ces
propositions de lois ne sont pas
adaptées à la nature du problème qui
nous est posée aussi pour la carte et
des débats je souhaite rappeler au
préalable ce que recouvre réellement la
participation de l'état aux charges
engendrées par ces dispositifs de
solidarité
s'agissant du rsa l'état a fait le choix
de procéder à une compensation similaire
à celle du rmi par versement d'une
fraction de tei pp qui est figé sur le
montant des dépenses engagées par les
départements en 2010 je rappelle au
passage que pour le rmi l'état avait été
au delà de ses obligations légales avec
le fond de mobilisation départementale
pour l'ess pour l'insertion qui voit son
existence conforter à hauteur de 500
millions d'euros par an pour la période
2011 2013
la contribution nationale au financement
de la paix à est quant à elle opérée via
la caisse nationale de solidarité pour
l'autonomie de ressources fiscales ont
été créés viennent alimenter le budget
de la cns à la contribution solidarité
pour l'autonomie et la contribution
additionnelle de 0 3% au prélèvement
social de 2% à 6 commencé sur les
revenus du patrimoine et les revenus de
placement qui s'ajoute à la fraction de
0 1% de csg
mais à la différence de la compensation
du rmi et du rsa
le montant annuel du concours de la cnf
ça n'est pas corrélée à la charge réelle
de la paix a pour les départements le
taux de couverture n'est donc déterminé
chaque année qu'une fois le budget de la
cns a exécuté ainsi de manière plus
générale je veux préciser car cela me
paraît important que la dépense publique
dépendance excède le seul financement de
la paix à part les départements on les
évalue aujourd'hui à quelques 22
milliards d'euros soit un peu plus de 1%
du pib' enfin s'agissant de la
prestation de compensation du handicap
à l'instar de la paix à une contribution
de la cns à participent à son
financement
s'agissant du reste à charge des
départements
je crois mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs qu'il faut que nous soyons
clairs sur ce point les auteurs de ces
propositions de loi ont opté pour une
présentation relativement imprécise qui
s'avère hélas tronquée quand on compare
les dépenses exposées par les
départements au titre du rmi rsa de la
paie acp et de la pch aux compensations
correspondante versée par l'état via la
tei pp le ffd y est les concours de la
cns a on observe un reste à charge qui
croît régulièrement du fait de l'effet
de ciseau que j'ai développé
précédemment
les auteurs des propositions de lois
l'estiment à quelques 3 8 milliards
d'euros en 2008 avec un taux de
couverture qui de ce fait est de 66 6%
de 4,5 milliards d'euros en 2009 un taux
de couverture de 63 26 % et autour de
5,4 milliards d'euros en 2010 ce qui
fait un taux de couverture de 67 25%
si la prod petula la progression pardon
est incontestable
les chiffres avancés ne sont pas exactes
ne sont pas justes en effet la
présentation aux mais ce qui est quand
même tout à fait impactant les produits
résultant des compensations transférées
au département depuis 84 au titre des
prestations légales l'aide sociale
versée aux personnes âgées dépendantes
et aux personnes handicapées psd intégré
à la paie acp et à cet ep intégré à la
pch
naturellement les quotes-parts de dmt ou
transférés en compensation de la prise
en charge des personnes dépendantes se
sont élevées en 2009 à 1 4 milliard
d'euros
la différence n'était donc plus en 2009
les 3 55 milliards d'euros que vous
pointez pardon je commets une erreur ils
n'étaient que donc de 3 55 milliards
d'euros soit un taux de couverture bien
supérieur à celui que vous annoncez
puisque ce taux de couverture était de
71 %
le gouvernement est conscient toutefois
que bien entendu le problème structurel
demeure cpp elle propose cependant un
mécanisme de compensation qui ne semble
pas adaptée à la nature des problèmes
rencontrés et qui par ailleurs va
largement au delà des obligations
constitutionnelles de l'état j'y reviens
dans un instant que propose en effet ces
deux propositions de loi la première en
première intention elle semble simple
voire à certains égards séduisante pour
le rsa et la pch l'état prendrait à sa
charge
ni plus ni moins l'intégralité du coût
de ses prestations supporté par les
départements pour la paix à le mécanisme
proposé en réalité s'avère
particulièrement complexe pour ne pas
dire résistant à l'intelligibilité
générale du système
il distingue en effet le calcul de la
compensation des charges liées à la paix
à domicile et à la paix en établissement
auquel est appliqué une franchise de 10
% ainsi que pour la paix à domicile une
minoration correspondant au montant
actualisé de la compensation versée en
2001 ou type de l'ancienne prestation
spécifique dépendance la psd au delà de
la complexité du système proposé
j'y vois un danger un danger pour les
départements car ces propositions les
déresponsabiliserait en quelque sorte
et au fond remettrait en cause la
décentralisation les propositions
formulées place à l'évidence le
département dans une position limitée à
la gestion d' allocation avec une
compensation intégrale des dépenses
engagées les départements n'aurait par
exemple plus aucun intérêt à vérifier
notamment la situation des bénéficiaires
plus encore ce n'est pas l'esprit qui a
présidé mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à l'instauration de ces
dispositifs
nous sommes ici au coeur du débat nous
ne pouvons considérer raisonnablement
ces trois dispositifs comme de simples
allocations de solidarité nous avons
affaire au contraire à des prestations
qui sont assorties d'un accompagnement
personnalisé évolutif
personne mieux que vous
ne le sait et ce sont justement les
services départementaux qui organise les
conditions et le suivi individualisé de
ces de cet accompagnement personnalisé
avec une dimension avec une dimension
contractuels pour le rsa avait un projet
de vie pour la pch et avec un plan daide
pour la paix un vouloir réduire ces
dispositifs personnalisé à des
allocations classique n'est pas la bonne
voie à suivre
y compris lorsque l'on se pose justement
la question de la pérennité de leurs
financements d'ailleurs un des avantages
majeurs d'une gestion décentralisée
n'est-il pas d'assurer une gestion et un
suivi adapté aux besoins réels de nos
concitoyens n'est ce pas du reste
l'intérêt financier du département que
de le faire au plus fin des réalités
sociales qu'il connaît si bien
c'est d'ailleurs mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs ce qu avait souligné le
sénat en 2007 dans un rapport sur le
contrôle comptable du rmi il n'est pas
raisonnable de faire dépendre
mécaniquement le versement de
compensations financières d'une
politique départementale à l'époque le
rapporteur de ce rapport
michel mercier avait montré brillamment
que la décentralisation du rmi avait
permis d'améliorer significativement la
qualité de la gestion de la location et
du fichier des bénéficiaires parce que
précisément les départements étaient
financièrement intéressé à cette bonne
gestion
ensuite permettez moi de vous dire que
l'idée d'un ticket modérateur de 10 %
proposés pour la paix a ainsi que votre
rapporteur le signal est il ya un
instant paraît relativement faible au
regard de la répartition actuelle de
cette charge
la réforme proposée par ses propositions
de lois remettrait donc en cause le
principe même de la décentralisation en
réduisant le rôle des départements à de
simples établissements publics mettant
en oeuvre localement une politique
nationale est ce vraiment ce que veulent
les auteurs de ces propositions de loi
je ne peux l'imaginer
par ailleurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ces
propositions de la de loi vont au delà
des obligations constitutionnelles qui
pèsent sur l'état
c'est un point important dans notre
débat cela a été souligné lors des
interventions et lors de l'une de ses
interventions puisqu'il sous-tend les
raisonnements que portent précisément
ces propositions de loi le conseil
constitutionnel a eu l'occasion
d'interpréter l'article 72 de la
constitution notamment par sa décision
du 13 janvier 2005 relative à la loi de
programmation pour la cohésion sociale
il a estimé que lorsque l'état transfère
aux collectivités territoriales des
compétences auparavant exercé par lui le
législateur était tenu de leur attribuer
des ressources correspondant aux charges
constatées à la date du transfert
or pour la paix un pour la pch et le rsa
dans sa partie socle majoré
nous sommes en présence d'extension et
non de transfert extension de compétence
à l'égard desquels il n'existe aucune
obligation constitutionnelle de
compensation intégrale des charges la
constitution imposant seulement aux
législateurs d'accompagner
financièrement ces extensions de
compétences de ressources dont il lui
appartient d'apprécier le niveau
ces propositions de loi crée une charge
excessive pour l'état même si le gage
convenons-en insuffisant que vous
introduisez permet de contourner
l'article 40 de la constitution
le coût pour l'état de la solution
proposée est d'abord excessif et
irréaliste dans le contexte actuel de
nos finances publiques
ainsi que l'a rappelé il y a un instant
votre président de la commission des
finances jean arthuis et vous même
monsieur le rapporteur en effet chaque
année au vu des comptes administratifs
l'état compenserait si je vous lis bien
à l'euro près le reste à charge des
départements le coût de cette solution
pour l'état aurait été en 2009 de 733
millions au titre du rsa 125 millions au
type de la pch pour la paix a un coût
pour l'état évalué à 2,7 milliards
d'euros pour 2009
au total les propositions de loi vise à
transférer des départements à l'état
une charge correspondant à 3 55
milliards d'euros sans modifier et sans
améliorer pour autant les dispositifs
perez a rappelé à et pch
quant aux gages proposé sur une
augmentation des droits sans tabac il
s'avère inapproprié car si je puis dire
décalé quant à son échelle il faut
savoir en effet plus une augmentation de
6% comme celle qui est intervenue en
novembre dernier le produit en année
pleine comme vous le savez mesdames
lycées les sénateurs qu environ une
recette de 400 millions d'euros
enfin et je veux m'arrêter un instant
sur ce point la réponse que vous
proposez est inadaptée face à un
problème qui vous le savez bien et
beaucoup plus globale car il s'agit
d'une question sociétale celle de la
prise en charge de la dépendance dans
notre pays l'analyse des données
chiffrées montre que la question de la
compensation des allocations
individuelles à la charge des
départements concernent très
majoritairement la paix à qui représente
plus des trois quarts du coût net de la
prise en charge des trois prestations
apa pch rsa pour les départements
j'ajoute que ce constat est renforcé par
une différence de dynamisme pour les
propres prestations à long terme
naturellement le nombre d'allocataires
du rsa et de la pch n'a pas vocation n'a
pas tendance à augmenter en pourcentage
de la population en dehors bien sûr de
ces périodes difficiles de mauvaise
conjoncture économique que nous avons
connue alors alors que le coup et vous
en conviendrez de la p1 parce qu'il est
structurelle devrait croître au fur et à
mesure de l'allongement de la durée de
vie et donc du vieillissement de la
population
ainsi aussi bien en termes de montant à
charge des départements à court terme
qu'en termes d'évolution sur la longue
période c'est bien la question plus
large de la dépendance qui est au coeur
du sujet la réponse à la situation des
départements passe donc aux yeux du
gouvernement par une véritable réflexion
sur la prise en charge de la dépendance
quelles sont en effet les réponses du
gouvernement au parlement le
gouvernement souhaite privilégier une
réponse en deux temps d'abord des
mesures ciblées et ponctuelle pour le
présent et si j'ose dire pour faire face
ensuite des réponses structurelles sur
la prise en charge de la dépendance pour
l'avenir d'abord la réponse de court
terme
à la suite du rapport de pierre jamet
comme vous le savez le premier ministre
après avoir rencontré le bureau exécutif
de l'adf c'était le 1er juin dernier a
décidé de mettre en place une mission
d'appui pour aider les départements qui
rencontrerait dès 2011 des difficultés
financière urgente
cette mission est à pied d'oeuvre elle a
d'ores et déjà été sollicité par
plusieurs départements
le travail entre cette mission et les
présidents de conseils généraux qui l'a
solliciteront pourra déboucher sur une
convention avec l'état portant des
mesures de soutien financier
je tiens à rappeler ici car c'est une
donnée importante que le recours à la
mission comme les échanges préalables à
la décision de passer ou non une
convention sont placées sous le sceau de
la plus stricte confidentialité fait la
condition d'une démarche à la fois
contractuels et respectueuse de la libre
administration par ailleurs le
gouvernement a décidé un moratoire sur
l'adoption des nouvelles mesures
réglementaires concernant les
collectivités territoriales il s'est
traduit déjà par la mise en oeuvre par
la circulaire du 6 juillet 2010 du
premier ministre pour les collectivités
territoriales dont les effets sont
immédiats et sont tangibles
parallèlement répondant en cela à la
sollicitation de son président alain
lambert il a accepté que la commission
consultative d'évaluation des normes
puissent étudier sur la base des
propositions formulées par la mf par
l'adf et par la rfl non plus simplement
le flux des nouvelles normes
réglementaires mais également son stock
de normes réglementaires va cumuler mon
collègue philippe richert ministre
chargé des collectivités territoriales
travaillera ensuite en concertation avec
les associations d'élus
à l'élaboration de mesures résultant des
propositions de la commission
consultative d'évaluation des normes
enfin mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le gouvernement a prévu des
mesures concrètes en plf 2011 et au plfr
pour 2010 une réponse structurelle avec
un dispositif innovant de péréquation
fiscale
il s'agit du fonds de péréquation ddmt
au dès 2011
il s'agit du fonds péréquation cvae
répartie début 2013 dispositif qui doit
contribuer à résorber en partie le
déséquilibre structurel de ressources
entre les départements la péréquation
verticale pardon et accentuer
parallèlement en matière de rsa le
gouvernement à veiller à appliquer
strictement la clause de revoyure prévue
par la loi en acceptant toutefois de
neutraliser ses effets à l'égard des 35
départements qui n'ont imputés aucune
dépense de rsa rsa socle majoré pardon
pour 2009 ou à montant significativement
inférieure à la dépense l'accueillît
supportés par l'état en 2008
ainsi le plf 2011 met en oeuvre la
seconde clause de revoyure qui se
traduit par l'ouverture de 975 millions
d'euros dont 840 millions d'euros sont
fléchés vers les départements
métropolitains de plus le plfr 2010 qui
est aujourd'hui en examen à l'assemblée
dispose la création d'un fonds des deux
départements en difficulté doté comme
vous savez 250 millions d'euros cet
amendement comme je le disais disputé en
ce moment même à l'assemblée comment
dirais je fusionne si je puis dire deux
enveloppes par ailleurs distincts de 75
millions d'euros qui seront
respectivement répartis entre les
départements connaissant des difficultés
financières particulières et qui auront
conventionnés avec l'état et entre les
30 départements les plus fragiles
au regard de la faiblesse de leurs
ressources du revenu moyen de leurs
habitants et de la proportion de
personnes âgées au sein de leur
population
la mission d'appui gf igas iga sera le
levier opérationnel pour analyser la
situation des départements
je cite mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ces quelques exemples pour
vous rappeler que dans ce domaine nous
agissons concrètement
car à nos yeux ces sujets sont très
importants il ne faut pas les traiter un
par un mais il faut s'efforcer de
réfléchir de manière approfondie durable
et globale c'est dans cette logique et
pour la longue période que le
gouvernement s'est engagé à ouvrir en
effet le chantier de la dépendance et ce
dès les semaines à venir le président de
la république l'a annoncé le 16 novembre
dernier
il s'agit d'un débat national sur la
prise en charge de la dépendance qui
doit se tenir dans le courant de l'année
2011 dans son premier semestre
précisément avant une inscription de la
réforme dans le projet loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2012 notamment c'est un enjeu primordial
aussi bien sûr évidemment pour les
départements au vu du très grand nombre
d'acteurs concernés par le champ de la
dépendance il est impératif qu'il soit
mené dans la concertation et que
naturellement les départements de france
ils prennent leur juste part toute leur
part plusieurs rapports ont éclairé ce
sujet complexe
je pense naturellement au report
gisserot rapport vasselle pauvres ceux
de bord celui de la cour des comptes qui
ont dressé des diagnostics qui ont
proposé un panel d'options envisageable
sur l'évolution de la gouvernance sur
les financements et sur le degré de
socialisation des dépenses de dépendance
il nous appartiendra donc collectivement
de dégager des solutions négociées des
solutions partagées je suis convaincu
que ce travail auquel seront associés
tous les groupes politiques formulera
des propositions susceptibles de nourrir
les initiatives législatives à venir
tels sont mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs les raisons pour lesquelles le
gouvernement souhaite que ces prêts que
ces propositions de loi ne soit pas
adoptée notre devoir est de laisser le
chantier de la dépendance se dérouler
d'élaborer des propositions et d'en
tirer les conséquences législatives le
moment venu notre devoir sera alors
examiné des textes mûrement réfléchie
préparé par des acteurs différents et
complémentaires notre devoir est enfin
il n'y a pas de différence entre nous
sur ce point de réfléchir sereinement
aux réformes importantes qui nous
attendent et qui permettront de faire
progresser tout à la fois notre
démocratie nous équilibres généraux dans
un souci partagé de la plus large
transparence possible
je vous remercie non c'est même le
ministre dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole l'état yves
krattinger pour le groupe socialiste
pour dix minutes
salut
beaucoup
monsieur le président madame la ministre
michelle collègues je commencerai en
saluant l'immense travail qui a été
effectué sur cette thématique au sein de
l'assemblée des départements de france
adf et donc le congrès d'avignon en
octobre dernier fut sans conteste le
point d'orgue
je salue la présence parmi nous de son
président claudy lebreton le son vice
président qui a beaucoup travaillé sur
le dossier michel dinet ainsi que celle
d'un certain nombre des représentants
des départements
jamais jusque là nous n'étions pas
revenue à une telle convergence pour ne
pas dire unanimité unanimité d'abord sur
la nécessité d'un engagement des
départements dans la mise en oeuvre des
solidarités sociales la part la pch
le rsa ensuite unanimité sur un constat
l'effet de ciseau très importants subis
par les départements en raison
essentiellement de la compensation
insuffisante par l'état du coup des
trois allocations de solidarité
unanimité enfin sur la nécessité d'un
acte législatif pour régler ce problème
qui est structuré la séance
d'aujourd'hui est donc une première
victoire pour celles et ceux nombreux
qui pensent que la solidarité nationale
n'est pas un vain mot et que des
réponses sont urgents pour la viabilité
à long terme du pacte républicain et
pour les départements en termes de
financement sur le court terme il s'agit
d'une première étape parlementaire d'un
combat qu'il faut poursuivre pour que
les conseils généraux restent en
situation d'agir quotidiennement à
l'amélioration du bien-être de nos
concitoyens en concrétisant les
solidarités sociales
territoriales plus personne ne conteste
sérieusement la spécificité des
difficultés budgétaires rencontrées par
les conseils généraux aucun autre niveau
de collectivité ne subit un tel décalage
entre la progression rapide de ses
dépenses qui sont obligatoires et la
stagnation de leurs recettes
évoquant ce phénomène de désajustement à
l'occasion de l'examen de la première
partie du projet de loi de finances pour
2011 le 22 octobre dernier
notre collègue rapporteur du budget à
l'assemblée nationale a eu ces mots très
justes et je le cite quand vous gérer au
plus près que vous réalisez toutes les
économies possibles et que malgré tout
vous rencontrez des difficultés c'est
que quelque chose ne va pas dans la
structure même des financements il
parlait des conseils généraux gilles
carez a parfaitement raison quelque
chose ne va pas et ce dérèglement est à
chercher dans la nature même du système
de compensation mis en oeuvre depuis
2002 nous en convenons en octobre 2009
la cour des comptes estime est déjà à
propos du financement de la
décentralisation et je la cite que les
mécanismes retenu n'apparaissent ni
satisfaisants ni viable à long terme
dans le domaine social et il parlait des
départements or dans le projet de loi de
finances 2011
rien rien de pérenne n'a été proposée
bien que nous ayons eu à débattre de
cette question à travers de nombreux
amendements
ainsi les départements doivent faire
face à des dépenses sociales rsa pch a
pas croissante près de 13 milliards et
demi d'euros en 2010 et le reste à
charge nette supportée par eux pour la
seule année 2010 atteint un montant de
5,3 milliards d'euros
on peut d'ailleurs noter pour un
département celui que j'ai l'honneur de
président
et qui figurent dans les dix
départements les plus pauvres que la
compensation 2010 madame la ministre
atteint seulement 54 % des dépenses des
allocations de solidarité cela traduit
en plus un traitement injuste des
inégalités territoriales dans la manière
dont sont répartis les compensations
face à ce constat partagé bien au delà
des 102 départements de france que nous
propose aujourd'hui le gouvernement
voilà donc pour la séance de cet après
midi consacré à la compensation des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire le journal de
19 heures présenté par michel grossiord
puis le 22 heures sonia mabrouk et bien
sûr vous pouvez toujours retrouver la
séance en vod sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne soirée sur notre chaîne